bonjour à tous ce matin les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 et dans son à l'article 15h qui
porte sur la réaffectation des recettes
entre le différentes branches du régime
général depuis mardi les sénateurs
détricotent soigneusement le texte et
ils ont supprimé l'article 8 qui porte
sur la fiscalisation de l'épargne
l'article 9 l'article 10 l'article 12
TER qui porte lui sur les mutuelles
l'examen du texte devrait s'achever
prématurément aujourd'hui alors que
l'ordre du jour était ouvert jusqu'à
samedi et le chevet aujourd'hui car les
sénateurs devraient rejeter la troisième
partie consacrée aux recettes l'examen
de la quatrième partie consacrée elle
aux dépenses deviendraient donc caduque
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
saint Jean-Claude Carl vice-président
UMP du Sénat qui préside la séance
l'ordre du jour rappelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2014 dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'article 15 TER et je suis
saisi d'un amendement 109 c'est Monsieur
Milan qui le défend vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord
bonjour
ensuite je vais vous présenter donc cet
article 15 TER alors que durant toutes
ces dernières années la majorité
d'aujourd'hui n'a cessé de demander la
baisse du taux de la taxe spéciale sur
les conventions d'assurance sur les
contrats responsables aujourd'hui la
seule solution trouvée pour les rendre
attractifs et d'augmenter la fiscalité
sur les contrats non responsables en
portant le taux de 9 à 14%. une nouvelle
fois pour trouver des recettes vous
augmentez les taxes les contrats non
responsables sont proposés par des
assurances des mutuelles ou des
institutions prévoyance et vise une
certaine clientèle ils font pleinement
partie du marché des contrats santé
prévoyance en décidant d'augmenter
encore cette taxe vous allez vous rendre
responsable d'une hausse des primes or
ces contrats répondent à l'attente d'une
catégorie de la population disposée à
souscrire ce type de contrat mais il est
vrai qui est toujours plus facile
d'augmenter des taxes plutôt que de
trouver des mesures d'économie nous
proposons donc la suppression de cet
article merci avis de la commission sur
le rapporteur
monsieur le Président de la ministre
chers collègues cet amendement propose
de supprimer l'article qu'un stère qui
fixe à 14% le taux de la taxe sur les
contrats non responsables et non
solidaires
à l'inverse ce qui va être dit je pense
qu'il convient de ce féliciter de
l'introduction par l'Assemblée nationale
de cette mesure qui permet en fin
d'établir un véritable écart de taxation
entre les types de contrats
complémentaires santé cette mesure est
cohérente avec le dispositif de
l'article 45 qui renforce ces critères
d'éligibilité des contrats responsables
et solidaires il me semble logique que
l'application d'un taux réduit bénéficie
à des contrats qui respectent des
critères de qualité et de pertinence des
prises de charge pour autant la
commission des affaires sociales dans sa
majorité n'a pas suivi mon avis et a
donné un avis favorable à l'amendement
merci avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
un avis défavorable à cette amendement
de suppression quel est l'enjeu l'enjeu
et de mieux réguler les
complémentaires santé qui sont proposés
à nos concitoyens en réintroduisant un
écart de fiscalité significatif entre
les contrats d'irresponsables et
solidaires d'une part et les autres
contrats d'autre part à travers la
disposition qui a été réintroduite dans
le débat à l'Assemblée nationale on
introduit un écart de 7 points de
fiscalité à travers le relèvement de la
taxe pour les contrats qui ne sont pas
identifiés comme responsables et
solidaires et de cette manière là il
s'agit d'encourager une bonne couverture
complémentaire santé de nos concitoyens
à travers la valorisation des contrats
de meilleure qualité en tout cas qui
proposent une prise en charge
satisfaisante au regard des objectifs de
régulation de l'offre de soins
merci je vais donc mettre au revoir cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avis contraire
alors on va vous faire faire un petit
peu de gymnastique on va le faire par
acide quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté
et nous en arrivons à deux amendements
discussion commune le 281 rectifié qui
le défend
monsieur le Maine
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre c'est des
leurs années la situation sanitaire et
sociale des étudiants c'est dégradé
on constate une des mutualisations voire
pour certains renoncement aux soins ça a
été notamment relevé dans le cas du
rapport que l'on fait et pour la
commission des affaires sociales nos
collègues cadran et procacia
et pour répondre
à cette situation on présente un
amendement qui est celui-ci il faudrait
exonérer une semble-t-il de la taxe
spéciale sur les contrats d'assurance
régie par l'article 991 du code général
des
impôts les contrats de complémentaires
santé souscrits par les ressortissants
du régime étudiant de Sécurité sociale
afin de faire baisser le coût leur coût
en lien avec la refonte du contenu des
contrats solidaires responsables cette
exonération est limitée aux seuls
comptes à responsables régi par
l'article
871-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
merci le 188 monsieur Watrin non madame
Pasquet
et monsieur le Président je
remets mes mon collègue vous le savez
depuis le gouvernement de Nicolas
Sarkozy
qui a fait le choix de doubler la TSCA
pour les contrats responsables et
solidaires notre groupe combat cette
mesure et on demande sa suppression je
suis d'ailleurs assez étonné que le
groupe
UMP aujourd'hui vote contre son
augmentation mais bon en effet dans le
contexte actuel ou de plus en plus de
concitoyens peine à accéder aux soins où
il renoncent de ressources suffisantes
toutes mesures ayant pour effet
d'augmenter le coût des contrats
d'assurance complémentaires et
contre-productive le contrat solidaire
est responsable bénéficier d'une
fiscalité dérogatoire au contrat
d'assurance dit ordinaire en raison des
contraintes particulières qui pesaient
sur eux ainsi l'assureur doit respecter
l'esprit du parcours de soins et
notamment ne pas rembourser les
franchises la part du ticket modérateur
majoré ou les dépassements d'honoraires
des spécialistes consultés en dehors du
parcours de soins d'une certaine manière
ces contrats participent donc déjà à
l'effort de réduction des dépenses de
santé afin de rétablir une véritable
incitation financière en faveur des
contrats solidaires et responsables et
de permettre à tous les étudiants de
pouvoir souscrire des contrats
d'assurance santé complémentaire nous
proposons que de porter de nous
proposons de porter à 3,5% le taux de
TSCA pour les contrats proposés par les
organismes d'assurance complémentaires
étudiants
merci avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
dans la ministre les deux amendements
280 rectifiés présentés par Monsieur le
Maine et 188 par Madame Pasquet vise à
faire baisser totalement au
partiellement le coût des contrats de
complémentaires santé responsable
souscrit par les étudiants toutefois on
ne prévoyant aucune condition de
ressources pour l'application de ce
dispositif il ferait bénéficier de cette
exonération fiscale l'ensemble des
étudiants y compris ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément besoin je proposerai à mes
collègues de soutenir plutôt
l'amendement proposant un taux de TSC à
réduit pour l'ensemble des contrats ACS
que j'aurais l'occasion de défendre au
nom de la commission celui-ci sera en
effet ciblé sur les publics les plus
fragiles en fonction de quoi la position
de la Commission est une demande de
retrait et à défaut la vie serait
défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
je demanderai aux auteurs de ces deux
amendements de bien vouloir les retirer
sinon je donnerai un avis défavorable
parce que au fond à travers un mécanisme
de taxation différenciée pour prendre en
compte la situation d'étudiants ou le la
condition d'étudiants on introduit un
principe de différenciation dans la
fiscalité
qui ne trouve pas nécessairement de
justification au regard d'autres
catégories de la population
prenons par exemple un salarié précaire
qui a de très faibles revenus pourquoi
et qui ne bénéficient pas de l'aide à la
complémentaire santé nous arrivons dans
un autre moment pourquoi faudrait-il que
les étudiants bénéficient d'une
situation plus favorable que ces
salariés avec de petits revenus nous
n'avons pas d'éléments objectifs nous
permettant de mettre en cause ce
principe
galité devant sa devant la fiscalité
aussi j'ajoute que il y a un vrai doute
constitutionnel sur
l'acceptabilité de tels amendements au
regard du principe d'égalité donc je
demande plutôt de